hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and i have another
hardware video for you guys and i
actually have my phone here because this
is a rapsol unboxing i know the the logo
is quite obscure right there uh but what
we're gonna do uh basically wrap so what
they're doing here i'll have their
website and their link in the
description uh they actually have a
youtube channel um but if they're
watching this now basically rapsol is a
company that uh does a bunch of those um
those transparent shields that go on
your uh your ipod your cell phone uh
whatever electronic device you may or
may not have uh so
i know this this is a it has a lot of
stuff on it this is what fedex did um
they tried to ship it to a po box but
they couldn't i guess uh shipped to a po
box so it was redirected to my house
and uh this is actually i did a hardware
overview of my phone already if you want
to watch that but basically this is the
uh invisible shield for the lg voyager
the lg vx 10000
actually
both on their website and on this
package here it says vx1000 i might
email wrapful about that
because it is in fact the vx
10 000.
uh so yeah here we go with the unboxing
video
take this open here
uh so yeah rapsol the only reason i'm
doing an unboxing video is because uh
wrap sole doesn't just give you uh one
invisible shield they actually give you
a lot of stuff with the invisible shield
i'm probably not going to install the
raxel in the video
but you see the hardware review you saw
yeah you've seen the hardware overview
so you can definitely go check that out
so here's what comes in the box or comes
in the little package
right here it says this is this uh
handy little meister for all sorts of
things a suntan lotion it's a glass
cleaner to cooking blah blah or just
cook with water so this is i guess their
little solution um
but you you know used to spritz on your
lg voyager or your electronic device
that looks fine to me
uh what we have over here is application
instructions so i can actually just grab
that right here here are the shields
themselves it looks like right under the
application instructions so i'll put
that there
so it says once you've applied your
rhapso film you can recycle the entire
box it's completely recyclable if you
can see that logo down there on the
right hand side
over here we have what looks like a
microfiber yes it says don't discard the
soft lint-free microfiber towelette with
a little rapsol logo on it very soft i'm
definitely going to take use of this i
have about six microfibers now but this
is looking good
and up in the top left-hand side this is
your squeegee to use to apply the wrap
so it's like
this hard rubber uh it's basically yeah
it reminds me of any other squeegee
you'd use it to get out your air bubbles
as you're applying the film uh to the
cover of the phone if i can get the
phone here as you're applying the film
you kind of push out the air bubbles
from the middle out so that makes sense
that they give you all these uh
different things uh in the box with your
rhapsody and it really makes a lot of
sense and i like i appreciate companies
that do include uh sorry that do include
a lot in their packages
so um thanks for wrap so for sending
this out to me and um i would definitely
get you guys with a full review video
there won't be an installation video um
you might be watching this after the gel
skins installation video and obviously
that wasn't the most exciting video in
the world
but yeah that was um that was what came
in the box with the rapsol and i will
get to you guys with a full review video
after i've installed the rapsuls and
that is basically it so thanks for
watching this video guys and i hope to
get you later in the next video uh
thanks for subscribing and thanks for
rating if you have already
um that is basically it so thanks for
watching guys peace